all right
if it is it is baby that's what they say
sometimes
you know
i used to go to the water park by my
house growing up
and it wasn't real close to us but it
was
you know close enough
you couldn't go barefoot over there you
had to put on shoes that's how far away
it was
and we go to the water park and uh
wasn't i mean it wasn't much of a place
you know the biggest attractions out
there they had um
a water slide
and they had uh
allegedly they had the coldest root beer
in the area
you'd go in there and people be like it
ain't that cold i can handle it you know
you know people drive down from the
north you know from canada and
saskatchewan
you know michigan
they drive down i can handle this i can
handle it
and they drive down there and i remember
you go in the general store over there
at that water park
it's called lando pines
and um you'd go in the general store
there and man it was when you even
opened the door to that general store it
was frosty in there
you see the polar express go by in the
distance
[Music]
and you get in there and you'd be
barefoot cause you just come from the um
you just come from the water slide in
the pool
and you'd be barefoot rocking around in
there and it's so cold
i remember as a child trying to get back
close to the uh cooler where that root
beer was
and i remember hugging that you'd hug
anybody was in here help me
i remember there was an old woman by the
baked beans one time and i just damn got
right up in between her legs for a
minute honestly
just trying to get to that root bear
and you'd get finally you get back near
the thing and you'd have you
two or three of us kids pulling on that
root beer on the
uh
the cage it was in it was in like a big
cage
big glass cage a big aquarium
you know because it was just you were so
powerful and so cold
and you'd have to pull on that door and
get your little buddy help me terrence
help
help terrence
and a little daniel be over there on the
other he'd be pushing against the damn
door he thought he was helping and he's
over there just you know
he's leaning on that bat like that come
on man
and finally you get it open you get that
door open
santa come walking out that [ __ ] i mean
it had been
you know
it was cold in there
santa come out you'd have a damn uh
um
you know a little uh
a damn penguin come walking out that
[ __ ]
and he'd been in there looking at
pornography and you're like damn how do
you know
how can he even touch himself he just
got them two rudders on him he don't
even have he can't grip nothing but he
was doing it anyway you could see the
shame on his face
but he'd get that the
glass door open and all these root beers
would be sitting there
you could barely see it was so cold
just fiercely coldness is coming at you
and the lady at the counter was like
close the door
and you grabbed one dude he took all the
energy you had inside just to grab one
and lock onto that
can
and you da at that moment you damned the
makers of the root beer
because why they put it in this cold the
can is cold
and you got and then you bounce that
thing all the way up to the register you
and your friend
tossing it to each other
you set it on the desk
on the counter
and that lady would be like you know
65 cents
and mommy giving you a little bit of
money
and you put your money up there and you
get it
and you walk out of there man and
just out into the distance
out into that just they're back into the
world the warm world
and you'd gone on an adventure you've
gone and you'd read you've gotten
something
you've gotten a piece of dang you've
gotten you a thing you'd gotten uh
you'd had a journey
getting that and then just so cold
and then you couldn't take your hands
off the can armor one time my hands got
stuck to the can
damn all day just
you know i look like a you know like one
of those guys outside of
a uh
of a macy's or something at christmas
you know trying to you know beg for
money shaking that can
you know i couldn't he just couldn't get
my hands off of the can i couldn't un
can my hands sure
those are the days man that's what i
miss about summer i miss going over
there orlando pines
and you'd want and sometimes they had
red root beer it was this barks root
beer and it was red red and you'd sip
that and make your lips all red and
pretty
and you'd wander right into that you
know
they had a lot of weird
perverts out there baby pedophiles out
there living out there barbecuing
you'd see a guy in the distance out
there you know
putting damn lotion on his arms and
grilling up a couple of
um
johnson's brats
like damn what's he you know a game he
had a family
you know and just
putting cologne on you'd see a man
putting cologne on by himself and
grilling wieners and grilling franks god
but those are the days man i miss that
about summer i miss that about being a
child when everything was an adventure
those days of even just being out there
at lando pines water park
and walking into that cooler
getting you a cold root beer
[Music]
you know everything when you're young
everything was an adventure
and i miss that
you know i do
let's get into it
come on baby
we gonna make it guys
we gonna make it
i'm gonna make it
so are you i'm gonna come up
yeah
[Music]
well
[Music]
well i just moved up to lucky street
when
[Music]
between you and me we got so much love
and in chemistry
[Music]
well good things keep on coming
[Music]
wow right there
and that's 89 volt
and they're singing the come up
you know and that's what you hat you
have to you have to believe that you're
on the come up that's a big thing
believing that there's something that
you are on a
on a on a forward turn
that you're on a that your projection
overall
is upward you got to believe that
you got to believe that
i hope you do
if you're feeling like you don't i hope
you i'll be able to just to remodel that
and don't listen to yourself for a
second and listen to me and let me tell
you
that you are
on the come up
you are
you are whatever you're going through or
dealing with or been dealt with
you know you playing blackjack with the
with the devil baby that's a life is
just you sitting right there hit me hit
me hit me
you know
and then bust damn
you know it's just so whatever you've
been dealt or you whatever you dealing
with just
slow the game down
look for the waitress order or water
you're gonna be fine
you're gonna be fine
um
man i uh oh i got to go see hank
williams jr last night
out here in the central east baby and if
you haven't seen this man
you know thunder head baby you know what
i'm talking about
this man he's a real rosta bout you know
he's a real uh
he's a real
he's like a like a
hmm
he's a
i mean he is just a damn super honky
that's what he is baby he's a real he's
got
i mean he's got music he's got music
built into him
you know
you pat him on the back a damn ballad
will come out of him
i bet when they burped him as a baby i
better you know a couple of b-flats fell
right off his tongue
i mean that felt he just he's got this
gumption in him
and a lot of you guys know who he is you
know he you know he's a legend
he's a legendary
and he's legend non-dairy he's like you
know he's he's he's probably also a
lactose free legend
because i don't know if legendary is
i don't know what that
i don't know if that's
cheese based or what it is
but he is um
he's a whisper he's this whispery
whiskey
whisker
cat
he's this
he's kind of this fat cat that that's
never been neutered kind of you know he
just
it was interesting to watch him
it was really interesting to watch him
um
i've gotten to know some of his family
over the years
uh
mildly
you know just by acquaintance and uh
anyway i got to go see him play live and
that was
uh that was quite a treat him and uh dan
auerbach
from the black keys were over there
and a lot of other beautiful women and
men i think
and somebody else was on stage they
could i think it was a woman or man it
could have been a man could have been a
thicker woman
not sure the angle i was at you know i
don't know but anyway
beautiful music
and uh and just a good time
and also i'll tell you what else i got
to see
i got to see you guys
i got to see you guys uh
went out to albuquerque over there i
haven't talked to you since that
alba care care
somebody's like say welcome to about
it's like how many casts are in abaca
i said man i'm happy to be here i said
he goes where and i said and they trick
you because they want to hear you say it
because they know you can't say it well
because nobody can because they can't
also
then the man said
i said i'm happy to be here the guy goes
where and i was like albert
yeah
albert
hey kitty
and the guy's like oh you mean alba
can't get cat cat kick cat
this uh the whole day
they don't even
if you look at it on the map it says
a-l-b-e-r-k
k-k-k-k-k and then has a bunch of just
dots
like what is it
one of the cues has a line going over
the top of it
you know like unlimited cues or whatever
damn you know
and one of the cues if you look real
close you can see him over there
carrying a couple other little cues on
his little
you know his little hip or whatever that
thing is a little goiter whatever cues
have on him
but damn it an albuquerque
that place is
that place is insane bro
i never seen anything like that bro
i know that people thank you first of
all for coming out
the show was good that that one was it
was a little tough in that venue i felt
like but it was good
um
and i was just so grateful i mean people
came out they got babysitters they drove
they made this effort
and they came to see me man and that's
what i'm saying thank you
thank you
thank you for that support
and i mean they had dang uh
[Music]
everybody people like dude they got
aliens man they got aliens bro
they have levatos that they got like
area uh quinceanos out there
hey dog
you believe in area quincy uno
like what
yeah don't you know what i'm talking
about
ailing is papa
like what though
like que paso pero
oh dawg i'm talking about aliens don't
you like area 51 though you know what
i'm talking about area
and i have a ticket
bro i [ __ ] and dude the crazy part is
everybody there is talking about aliens
and the aliens are the people bro
we went into the um
we went to a love's gas station because
everything shuts down and now be
hey
at probably about midnight
or probably 10 p.m
bro
we had to walk
because one of the ubers said the
command said i ain't coming over there
like all right [ __ ] my all right
you know we'll figure it out we'll do
old-fashioned
so we walked you know the original ubers
baby and i'm talking about feet and
kneecaps baby
that freaking ligament that them you
know
them little ligament uh
you know them bangers baby them lifters
legs
i was like all right we'll use these
[ __ ]
and uh so we start walking
first guy we see has a
sword
okay that's wild guy had a sword on him
he was a grown man too
and we just didn't want to kind of he
was he was a lot he was walking around
but you could tell he was asleep
so he's one of those sleep swords
so it was just one of those he's almost
like one of those like on a game on a
video game if you don't get close to
them they don't know you're there kind
of he was like yeah so like all right
let's just maneuver around
um this little guardian
of the uh greyhound he was basically
guarding a greyhound station
um but anyway what was i talking about
oh albuquerque yeah but everybody there
they talk about the alien but the aliens
are they are amongst the people they're
so mixed in
and we went to a gas station and this
guy in there was just walking like
just like
he moved like his head he kept moving
his arms up above his heads while he
walked like oh dawg i'm looking for
some rolos
i'm looking for what you might call it
and everybody there had a parole officer
with them
and that blew my mind
but that's solid police work
and um
and thank you that was that was great
man
over there and they have like hey yeah
that was great we saw that uh
what else happened man
um
yeah i try to do meet and greets after
the shows in most of the city i try to
pop out and say hey if i have the energy
for it um
and we made it over there through uh
midland and lubbock
and we made it over there through um
where else were we
dallas
beautiful man
you know thank you all to texas and then
we you know
this fast week we made it through
georgia and over there at alabama and uh
but what else happened oh oh also in
albuquerque they're like dog you got to
try the chili's dog have you had the
green chilies
dude somebody
that place is crazy dude uh
i went
i went to like this meeting there um
[Music]
you know i got 51 days sober right now
so
that's where i'm at and uh
i'm feeling very grateful for that
uh
and so i went to this me and the other
dude i know you're not supposed to talk
about what happens in meetings that's
fine i was at a meeting once then i'll
say it like this and it was just me and
someone else and the man
was hitting on me bro in there
like dude i'm trying to get sober dog
not gayed out
you know so it was just like dang bro
you gotta watch that stuff
so uh
if you're at a meeting and a guy takes
his shoes off dude
and um he started doing that cat's
cradle thing with his shoelaces he took
them out of his shoes and was doing
cat's cradle with them
i'm like god you know but um
but an abba
kiki
they always want you to try the green
chilies
people are like dawg my cousin got
attacked by two guys with um
lightsabers you know
but
have you had the green chilis like
that's all it is there
it's like man my friend got run over by
a volkswagen
but
um but have you had the green chilies
people like dude man uh my uh you know
my wife fell off a building last week
and it was
you know nobody knows what happened i
was up there with her and
we got an argument and she went off the
edge and uh
and damn have you had the green chilies
man because they are good
so it's just that kind of place it's
that green chili belt over there and
look i will say this they are good
everybody in albuquerque
seem like they are waiting for a
greyhound bus even if they're not at a
greyhound station
i feel like everybody has luggage
um
yeah
everybody like has a ticket like i'm
waiting for the train
and they're just there's not even near
any tracks it just is a unique area
you know even birds are like man [ __ ]
dawg
what the [ __ ] is happening here
um
but i'll say this to people that came
out beautiful folks
and uh
and thank you guys for having me man i
really appreciate it then we made it
through lubbock and midland and over to
dallas and that was amazing and then uh
um
what else oh we went to savannah georgia
we got a lot more things talking about a
lot of great calls came in man
um
and i'm feeling good
[Music]
and i'm feeling good and i want to thank
you guys for your support
um i want to let you know that oh i will
be in florida
in two weeks you know you can see me
over there
on june 23rd hollywood florida june 24
fort myers
florida june 25 daytona beach florida
and june 26 lakeland
florida
um
yeah and also want to let you know that
we have um
the nba championships are going on
you know it's dallas and golden state
and uh you can join the finals action
with draftkings sports book
they're an official sponsor
uh official sports betting partner of
the nba
new customers can make any five dollar
mba bet and get 150
in free bets instantly wow that's
beautiful
if you're looking to turn a small bed
into a big payday during an nba finals
with draftkings same game parlay you can
do that
this nba season a customer placed a five
dollar same game parley and one over
five thousand dollars that's amazing
download the draftkings sportsbook app
now use promo code t-h-e-o
make any five-dollar bet during the nba
finals and get 150 in free bets
instantly that's promo code theo only at
draftking sports book and official
sports betting partner of the nba
minimum asian elitability restrictions
applies his show for details
um
and we uh
we have notes a disclaimer for that in
the uh episode of the show and the
show's notes and also if you have a
gambling addiction or something like
that then i recommend that you do not
gamble and that you reach out for
help what else
oh i want to say protein powder can be
intimidating
you know sometimes you open up a can and
you hear guys in there and they're you
know
they're they have baseball bats and
they're really you know they're talking
smack and stuff and you're like oh this
protein powder sounds is intense
um but the fact is we all need protein a
great percentage of your body is protein
think about that
look at an animal
touch it
what's that protein mostly
it's not just about muscles protein
helps support
bone health
and satia and satiety it's a tidy
and as we go through life protein needs
change so it's important to choose a mix
for different life stages rituals
rituals essential protein is the
delicious plant-based protein powder
with three distinct formulas designed to
meet the body's changing protein needs i
like this plant protein man i like plant
protein
they have the daily shake 50 plus which
adds calcium hmb to the mix helping to
build and maintain muscle mass for
healthy active aging if you are aging
calon
they have daily shake pregnancy and
postpartum
if you have a baby uh or your pregnancy
or lactation this sh this this stuff
will bounce you up get you ready rock
you feed that baby with that dang milk
rocket
so the ritual difference uh
one-of-a-kind visible supply chain you
know what how and why of every labeled
ingredient
they even offer a money-back guarantee
for not 100 in love there you go tpw
listeners get 10 off with your first
three months at
dot com slash t-h-e-o
visit ritual dot com slash theo today
for ten percent off your first three
months thank you for supporting the
podcast
and just thank you guys for coming out
man just seeing everybody's faces
getting to shake hands with people
um
and
just to be in the same room you know uh
i wish i could just spend the hour just
get off the stage and walk around and
give a damn hug to everyone
um
but
uh
but we did what we could
and thanked everybody that came out
where else
what else can we talk about here um oh
the bus broke down that bastard now
that thing had some i mean it was
i mean that thing it looked like it had
it was just made out of dang uh
you know like um
it would look like it would just have
that dirty diaper vibe from the jump
it was uh
i know there was a pair of um
men's boots small men's boots under my
bed
and it was interesting i thought there
was children's boots when i saw him i
said this is children's boots and
it's a little creepy to have children's
boots under your bed on a bus that's you
know strange
and the bedding looked like they had
just beaten it out of clint eastwood
like somebody tied it up and they just
punched him so many times that a damn
you know bedroom set popped right out of
his
skull
it was just had her old you know older
motif kind of uh western
kind of
you know uh kind of like somebody
you know
so i don't know you could i bet it felt
like something bad had happened to
native americans in the area of the
blanket that's what it felt like if it
was an old blanket
anyway they had children's boots under
the bed but on the back of the
children's boot it said men's on it
and that's when you got to really
question what's going on
when somebody's writing men's
on the back of a children's boot
so
so anyway what else do we have man um
a lot of people came out
people with damn tits people one leg no
leg half
dude came out half a head dude came out
no teeth bro lost all his teeth he said
for two years he's had no teeth
and um
beautiful
beautiful dude i don't know what he also
he started saying something else i had
no idea what he said because the teeth
help a little when you word now but that
fella came out a couple people with wet
hands came out i remember that
um
somebody oh people left gifts
a lot of nice things this and that
um and then we hit also uh
some other places out there savannah
uh
and
um
augusta georgia
and that play i mean some of these town
you get out i mean augustine there's
nothing downtown
they're not even a goat you can't even
they don't even do uh
montgomery we went to alabama
you know um that's rosa parks country
over there
and rosadom park somewhere else because
there's nobody downtown there either
that place i mean they didn't even have
ghosts even the ghosts are gone they
used to do ghost tours and now i thought
so i think that ghost tours closed
even the ghosts
have left
and that's when it's
you know when not only do humans leave
but then even the spirit you know
you know that there's a there's a bus
full of you know just realms and
and ghosts
leaving town
i'd love to see the cops pull that bus
over
just stops and just know the
license registration there's just
nothing to sit in there
[Music]
okay
um
but yeah man just great shows thank you
to everybody that came out a lot of
great energy just beautiful folks and
uh i wish i'd gotten this hey today to
everyone in person but just a lot of
kind messages and and things that i did
hear from people and so thank you
uh what else man
um oh my boy ty ernie came out growing
up this fellow he grew up named tight
ernie
and he was tight boy his body was just
damn i mean just condensed like a damn
twix bro
you know his spine was real narrow
you know like one of those kind of fat
orange extension cords that [ __ ] was
real
i mean it was a just a
you know it was just a
you know it was that
it was a
it was a lean portal he had on him he
was just real his whole body was tight
and condensed you know
um if he lifted his right arm you know
to shake your hand his left leg would go
up
he was just his whole body was just real
condensed like that
and uh they call him tight ernie baby
and he's you know he could hear i mean
it sounded when he his windpipe was
tight
he was you know he had that tight pipe
on him
and when he talked it was
hey
[Music]
[Music]
i mean like his daddy had just damn
[ __ ] a flute
you know what i'm talking about somebody
in that family you know
got a little uh
risque with a um
what is it with a woodwind you know what
i'm saying you know somebody definitely
somebody was
somebody was putting wood into a
woodwind baby in that family because
that dude [ __ ] damn boy
and i grew up with that fella man so
it's just crazy to see him
some folks brought him out because he
can't drive he can't handle that
steering wheel
you know watching him drive it's like if
you see somebody put one of those the
club they used to put the club on their
car
on the steering wheel somebody steal it
that's like watching him drive he's just
so tight and concise
you know he's just built like a damn um
you know he's built like a uh let me
look at these woodwind instruments
what are nine women oh yeah he's built
like a damn oboe
or a bass clarinet bruh
there you go
um
but yeah
great times man great times what else
happened
everything man you guys had some calls
that's really what i want to get to i
want to get to you guys calling in and
uh just hear what's up with y'all you
know
um
[Music]
but
yeah i'm just trying to stay alive and
stay happy and stay well man and i hope
that's the same thing that you are doing
um
i know you are
what else do we have some calls came in
let's just get into a couple
um
i felt like it was something else fun i
was gonna tell you but
might have forgot it
oh the bus broke down and they gave us a
new bus they got us a new bus took a
couple days
but we drove for like nine hours just in
the back of the bus no power nothing
just hot in there just bacon i mean just
you know
like somebody just like the toaster you
know just like a little toaster
and that [ __ ] i got out of that thing
finally i wanted to put damn butter on
my back and eat my ass bro you know what
i'm saying dude it just
you know i wanted to put a dang little
uh preserves up and down my
legs and back because i would lightly
i'm just a little bit browned on the
outside brother you know what i'm saying
affirmative action baby
that affirmative action stroller that's
what we were in because i was just baked
when i got out that bad boy i was
browned out praise god
now before we get into um
the new the
the calls let's get into a little bit of
news
a little bit of intel baby and you know
what i do for my news baby i take my
news straight out of the nearest asian
baby right off the press baby
god's freaking publishing company bro
you know what i'm talking about
there is that that's facts that's all
facts you cut you you freaking get to
know a good asian person and that's
facts son
xerox ain't got [ __ ]
on a good vietnamese friend brother a
polynesian
what you got there riley mao
uh nothing much great to be here
yeah nice to hear you today man you
sound um
your voice sounds a little bit deeper
say something for me
uh hey theo how's it going
yeah it's interesting have you been
doing any different activities you know
uh do you give a birthday have you been
um
eating anything that would make you
sound stronger doing any
thing like that manly stuff you've been
watching any uh fights or westerns
anything going like that in your world
um i've been
drinking lots of protein powder eating
lots of protein oh really yeah oh wow
and what's got you doing that
um i'm actually with a trainer he's been
um
working out with me
oh that's great man and what are some of
your long-term goals with uh fitness
uh just to you know be fit don't get fat
um
you have fat family
i do not praise god brother
ah it's hard to trust a fully lean
family i've always thought if i see a
family and everybody's lean it's hard to
tell to trust everybody over there um
what else is going on with you man you
do you feeling good
i did have a kidney stone you did i did
wow and woody what do you think it was
caused by a damn baby that's the lord's
fruity pebble dog and you had that [ __ ]
huh yeah i have no idea um
i'm supposed to find out from the doctor
in a little bit and how big was it they
let you keep it
no they didn't let me keep it but i
caught it and it's like
very very small wow
like a pebble
and um
what did you do you turned it in
yes
wow
because i don't know if those are catch
and release or not i don't know what the
legal
i don't know what they let you do there
uh
i don't know what the you know park
rangers or whatever would do with that
but
because i you know i'd be damn you get
pulled over and you got five or six of
those and you're
you know in your car or whatever
um
yeah we had a buddy in high school his
dad had him he
took him one at a party and drank three
of them and then he had to get him um
surgically removed out of his uh
penis
so what's up with you and god baby how's
god treating you riley uh he's great
isn't he yes he really is man man
he has just all the silverware brother i
know that
and when i need us when i just need
something to pick me up he's got a fork
a spoon
i mean i need something to just ding you
know
just
slice right into my damn heart he's got
a knife
praise god brother
uh in the news what do we got there
raleigh anything happening in the news
um let's see a disney worker ruined a
proposal
oh really let me see do we have a video
is that here yes
let me look at this
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know what it is man and i don't
want to say this really and i don't know
this
but a lot of uh uh uh disney is known
it's really a hotbed for um
a lot of gay men
go work day it's their first step out
into
uh a place where they're really i think
you know a lot of it's a mecca for gay
men it's basically the wailing wall
in a lot of ways or it's like um
what's another mecca rally
um
like a popular place people go to
build a bear
no that's that's
no like a popul popular place that
people go to
like a you know a national monument or
something
all right thank you for the help brother
it's um
you know it's like a
uh
disneyland has long been a hotbed for
it's like a it's kind of a uh
homoerotic sort of um
a halfway house
for young gay men i believe have you
ever heard this rally
i have
and there you go
and um
and so i don't want to i don't know what
this is maybe this guy doesn't believe
in
opposite sex marriage or something i
don't know
uh
so i'm not accusing anybody i'm saying
that that could be something
that has occurred
um there could be some opposition to
that in that realm
uh you also
uh maybe they just don't let people get
married there
because if you notice a lot of the
different
cartoons don't have parents
they want you to believe they all
magically occurred and there wasn't any
sex you know
nobody wants to think of like a wet uh
what's a popular disney character riley
mao
mickey mouse
nobody wants to think of us you know
mickey mouse covered in amniotic
and little you know maybe a couple
duties under him or whatever from a
crazy birth
you know from coming down the damn um
you know the uh thunder mountain mom's
thunder mountain so
praise god baby
but uh yeah i guess they they're they
the man said no he said you go on out of
here
and come back with a faint comeback with
a pretty little
come back with a buddy
or something who knows i don't know but
they're not letting them do it
and uh it's kind of bummer i think if
you you see that in the wedding video
just promotes disneyland but maybe
they'd have people doing it all day so
that could also be an issue what else we
got right let's get into one more news
story
um let's see
oh
uh some tick tock pediatricians urge
people to stop sharing dangerous baby
formula recipes
okay and when you baby formula riley you
remember you uh
were you on the on the bag are we on the
tit
i don't remember
no recollection
no
even if you purse your lips a little
does anything come back to your memory
no
nothing to mind
well they say yeah people are making
dirty baby formula on here
um
i'm i'm i'm not shocked you know people
are doing stuff on ticket tick tormula
on tick tock tick tick tick tock people
doing bad stuff on there
everything fake gasoline
all kind of [ __ ] that people said they
came back from the past and [ __ ] on
there time travelers all this [ __ ]
people believe it
people believe it and
you know i guess it's you know i think
if you go in there to get a recipe for
you know a um
a bouillabaisse or a good soup that's
quality but if you go in there to get a
damn uh something to put into a damn
newborn
you're gonna put a damn 98 octane into
that bastard
or put something you know
has a
afrin in it or something like that
that's poor choice
that's poor choice
what else okay
let's do a couple more ads and we'll get
into some calls man we have some great
ones from you guys mud water i want to
let you know
is a coffee alternative with four
adaptogenic mushrooms and ayurvedic
herbs
with one-seventh of caffeine as a cup of
coffee you get energy without the
anxiety jitters or crash of coffee
now a lot of people don't want to do
something new in this realm but you
don't realize that coffee sometimes can
actually
there's so much rattling in it that it
can hurt you
each ingredient was added for a purpose
cacao and chai for mood
and a micro dose of caffeine lion's mane
for alertness
cordyceps to help support physical
performance chaga and reishi to support
your immune system turmeric for soreness
and cinnamon for antioxidants
and man let me just tell you there is a
comfort
when you take this that you
you feel like you have more of a control
over what's going in you then just
dousing yourself with that dirty
freaking you know
just that primatish coffee
so um yep you'll enjoy it uh you can add
some honey if you want you can add a
little bit of nut milk if you want and
look get that out of whatever nut you
want baby that's god's plan
mud is
whole 30 approved 100 usda organic
non-gmo gluten-free vegan and kosher go
to mud water mud wtr.com
theo to support the show and use code
theo for 15 off that's right go to
mudwtr.com
theo and use code theo for 15
off
you know it can be hard sometimes to see
the light at the end of the tunnel
it really can you know you you stand in
the year in the dark you don't even know
it
and that's what happens a lot of times
with a high interest debt
and high interest credit card debt
you know i had a card i was paying on
for a while i didn't realize i was
spending about an extra 70 a month
it took me about a year and a half to
realize like dang man i could have been
saving but i didn't know
can't be too hard on myself
upstart
powered personal loans can help you pay
down high interest debt all online
with simple and easy to use under easy
to understand payment terms they've
helped over 1.8 million
upstart has helped over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom that's right upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
so rather than looking at your credit
score alone upstart's model considers
other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
that's amazing
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars don't wait and check
your rate today at upstart.com
theo that's upstart.com
t-h-e-o to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you
loan amounts determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your application
goodupstart.com
theo
all right let's get into a couple calls
here from you guys thank you and as
always the hotline is 985-664-9503
theo is jonah from seattle washington
man and i just
jonah
up there
and jonah's a faint name of a famous
whale too if you ever looked at that
in the bible or in um
i don't know if it's in the bible or if
it's just
just just outside of the bible but jonah
was a famous whale
onward
in seattle area man we get pretty crazy
with the weed man and
you know i grew up ever since i was 13
been smoking weed um and it's definitely
an area in my life that
you know nothing wrong with it but it's
an area in my life i want to grow in
because i can tell it's definitely
taking a strong grip um oh yeah
weedle uh
it's comfortable
it's comfortable
it's like walking around with a you know
just a pillow just you know
party it's like a pillow party hey
i'm having fun my brain's kind of fun
looks cool looks cool out here what's
going on oh i lost my job
oh
oh all right
oh dunkin donuts
you know that's weed let's hear it
my life you know and um i definitely
don't know how it is in louisiana i was
wondering
out there in louisiana man what does it
look like dealing with the people who
are always stoned do you even see them
well look brother i'll tell you this man
i grew up in louisiana and it's a
beautiful place dude if you believe in
beauty then you uh
you believe in that state
and it's one of the top 50 states and
it's
louisiana purchase we did that
so
half y'all would be canadian if we
hadn't done the deal
you're welcome
but i want to say this i remember weed
was fun
weed was fun back in the day
you know you get that swamp gas baby
start huffing it up and that [ __ ] was
brown bro some of it have a damn gator
claw in it or a damn little falcon half
a falcon nut in that bastard weed
louisiana weed baby damn
that thing bro you take a hit of it and
the water level in your yard would rise
that [ __ ] would whoo
and she was thick boy that [ __ ] was
thick
you know that thing dude you damn uh
i mean they had just trimmed baby that
[ __ ] was that [ __ ] you know
that [ __ ] that
they trim those reggie bushes bro and
you hit that slam jordan dog you know
what i'm saying baby that [ __ ] was south
and i loved getting high as a child was
great i don't care where you were
you know uh
dude
i remember the weed you get a bag of
weed on it if you didn't want to uh
smoke it they'd have a damn recipe for
you
uh
make you a little bit of a2 faded you
know
some um
you know get you a little bit of uh just
that gumbo
just that freaking get your brains all
you know
get of your brain just [ __ ] looking
for itself bro
you know you could feel your brain
looking for itself dawg that should get
you gassed up
that shit'll have you singing the
national anthem bruh
at a um
that [ __ ] will have you singing a
national anthem to a spice rack dog
that's that louisiana swamp gas yeah
getting high in louisiana was fun man as
a child and getting high anywhere as a
child is great if you can do it do it
then and do it well and do it high
and i remember we used to be over at my
buddy's house
and um
we used to get high over there
and his daddy wasn't super his daddy
wasn't super fond of gays at the time he
didn't he wasn't anti-gay he just didn't
know anything about it and it made him
real uncomfortable
um so me and my friend and my other
friend we go outside we smoke weed i'd
come back in early to the house i'd be
the first one back in and i would go to
my buddy's dad i would know about that
kind of gay trigger he had
and i would just tell them i'd be like
hey mr mike you know uh
you know they were kind of being a
little
i don't know what they were doing sir
they just
i saw them kind of like
you know once somebody took their shirt
off for no reason outside i just some of
this stuff was just
made me uncomfortable right
so then my two buddies would come back
into the house stoned out the gills baby
i mean just [ __ ] fish food and baby
they weren't doing well
and now suddenly my buddy's dad is
grilling them about being gay and they
don't know that i told the uh the dad
the stuff so
i used to love that kind of [ __ ] man
create an ambiance
you know create an ambiance that um
you know it was just so good
that's it was fun maybe those are the
good old days uh you ever you ever done
anything like that riley you never
smoked any weed have you bubba
i have not
and are you afraid do you believe that
getting high could leave could lead
people to homosexuality
possibly
i mean there's a lot of there was a lot
of drug induced uh
gay activity when i was young but that
was higher octane drugs you're looking
at methamphetamines looking at stuff
like that
but low-grade branch dope i don't know
if that would get somebody all the way
to the you know onto another fellow's
peg or
or sweat wallet you know
if it's women let's hear more let's get
another call that came in man um
yeah this is josh from australia my
topic is
nipple piercing
i've just recently started dating this
girl and she's got two nipple piercings
i don't really know what to think about
it i haven't read too much into it but
uh not someone know what your thoughts
are and the listeners thoughts on
chicks or dudes with nipple piercings
like what does that say about someone
look man i think it says for one that
they that they you know they got no
excuse not to have a spare house key on
them
that is for sure uh they should be able
to usually get one extra hanging on
there you know so that's not a bad deal
at all never get locked out
oh
that nipple piercing i think it's kind
of it definitely seems sexy on a woman
when you think she's got nails right
through her tits you know that's really
there's something erotic and almost
biblical about it you know
because they put god on the cross baby
so everybody kind of has had their
moment in the
you know in the metal sun
um if you will so i don't think it's
insane to want to get pierced up and
and uh put holes in your body or
something like that and i think if a
woman got it you know i actually made
love to a woman recently and she had she
was really uh
she had some piercings on her
you know she had them hooters really uh
had them you know i mean she'd taken
them hooters to
damn home depot baby you know what i'm
saying she had some real
um
you know she had some real uh
metallurgy done on those things i mean
it could have been a welder hanging off
the bottom of one of them [ __ ] baby
she had them think she had some real
you know she had some one of them had a
damn door knocker on it you know that
thing was hello
so
um
so yeah i like them i like them and oh
man i think it's crazy you know i
remember one time i was doing a tour
somewhere in africa
uh with military british military i
think and i fell in there he pulled out
his wiener and he had a big
piercing on it and it looked insane bro
and i think the guy was uh
you know what i'm saying i think the guy
had smoked a little too much weed if you
know what i'm saying bro you know what
i'm talking about so
praise god brother um
what else man
uh
[Music]
we'll do one or two more calls here i
appreciate you guys as always hitting
the hotline 985 664 985-664-9503
um here we go
okay
hear me out
i've been watching your podcast for a
while now
and
how would you
take this
or i ain't not a word
i don't know what to do
i [ __ ] my best friend's mom
and
she
won't leave me a world now
and
now i don't know what to do about it
so
well i think it's a question what kind
of friend are you brother
you know you you know if you made love
to your buddy's mother of course she's
gonna like you
because if it's your best friend he
likes you you're best friends
so you're just you know
he came out of her so you're going back
to the
you know you're going back to the front
porch of his creation and
hanging out there
so yes the mother's gonna like you the
kid likes you
you know your buddy likes you so
i think you gotta just hit for the cycle
dude and be a damn step dad brother
you know step up to the plate who else
you're gonna date you're gonna date
somebody across town
somebody that's working over there at
the dunkin donuts at the drive-thru or
something
somebody that's you know
somebody some weird person that when
they go to a restaurant they like fill
their hand up with like salt or sugar
and dip their finger in it while they're
waiting to eat dinner and lick it and
then lick the salt or sugar off
who are you gonna date somebody like
that
are you gonna date your best friend's
mom
and go in there and be a champion not
only for her but for your friend
imagine that
imagine one day you sit down with your
buddy and say hey man
i love you so much as a friend that i'm
gonna take care of your mother for the
rest of her life
when you come over on my grill for you
you know i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
angry at you i'm gonna [ __ ] make you
try and make you rake the yard
and i'm gonna fist fight you in your
mother and i's own yard
what do you want
what does god want
ah thank you guys so much for the calls
man i love you guys man um
all right all right let's take another
call here
hey theo is designing from uh eating in
oklahoma
uh
went to tulsa to see you recently loved
it it was great
thank you man thank you for coming out
and thank you for uh
spending your time over there yeah that
was exciting dude that was an exciting
night onward
i was just wondering if you had even the
advice
um
i let my
the mother of my child down recently
at least i have been for the past two
years and
i wasn't drunk
i'm
finally realizing everything and trying
to be better but
apparently it's too late so you know
remind me if you have any advice on how
to keep on going man
love you
you help me
get through the hardest things
thank you so much deal
thank you bro for the call man um
i'm sorry that you're that you're
suffering uh
but also i'm glad that you are
you know uh
and i say this this is why i say that
um
[Music]
because
you know it sounds like you have some
realization now you're able to get some
perspective maybe
that the way you've been operating has
investments servicing you
or those you care about the most
you know
you know i don't have a wife or child or
anything like that but
yeah it breaks my heart because i know
it breaks your heart man
you know
i know it breaks your heart to see you
make the choice
to not choose them
and that i can relate to
you know i can relate to making choices
that uh
that don't serve you
or me you know or you know i can relate
to making a choice that i know isn't
good for myself and i do it again and
again
i can relate to that man um
[Music]
so that's where i'm going to try to
relate to you at
uh
[Music]
for one thank you for even thinking to
bring this up
you know because i'm sure a lot of
people struggle with this kind of stuff
and i say that i'm glad you're getting
you know you're so i'm glad you're
suffering i'm glad you're suffering but
i'm glad that you're having some some
realization because there's some
realization there in that suffering
there's some perspective
um because we need that we need
something to adjust the perspective
enough so we can see that the operating
we're doing isn't doing us well
and if i'm not operating well then that
means that there's something wrong with
the operation or the operator that's me
there's something unaligned it's not
wrong it's just something on the line
because i'm not choosing the best
choices that are making me feel good
um
[Music]
and so i got to adjust and for me that's
where you know going leaning back into
my program 12 steps that kind of stuff
helps immensely
it does magic behind the scenes that you
can't even quantify
um
and it takes away that shame that's what
i hear in you too i hear shame
i hear shame man damn
and shame is what shame is that trick
shame is a trickster
shane's play you know
shane plays a dirty trombone dog
that's a little soil soldier dog that's
all he's got
in that uh
and that music maker is sod bro
because he he's a dirty shame is a dirty
because you start hearing feeling your
own shame and that that keeps you stuck
shame is a mud
it's a real mud
so anyway man i'm saying a lot of that
stuff because uh
now you have some perspective so now you
can see you got to make some adjustments
so that you making different choices
towards the people you care about the
most
um
and it's possible that's what i'm going
to tell you here i'll take these off too
i don't want to be talking serious with
you
not be able to see you or as best i can
um
[Music]
you know it's hard to choose love
sometimes in the world it's hard
it's hard
and i don't know why you're not doing it
in your life i don't know why
but there's a lot of people out there
not doing it
you know i've not done it a ton there's
areas of my life i'm not doing it
i'm choosing something else and i don't
know why
and you know what i don't exactly have
to figure out that why what what i do
have to do is just get myself into a
place where i'm choosing the things i
need to be choosing and so that's where
i believe that a 12-step program can
help you out
because that has been the best success
that i've had after all the things i've
tried
that program i feel like is best giving
me the opportunity and the different
feelings inside
to have a new experience
and it's not over with the gal that's
not over
she can't tell you that everything's
gonna be okay right now that's not fair
that'll keep you in the same spiral
you know if she throws a life preserver
into the toilet you still in the toilet
you know the same baby that you know we
got to get you into a damn bird bath dog
that's where we got to get you
um
so
just don't be hard on yourself
just try not try not to be hard on
yourself and i think try something
different you know i think trying a
12-step program will help a lot let me
listen to the end again so i can hear
just again in case i missed anything for
the past two years and
i wasn't drunk
i'm
finally realizing everything and trying
to be better but
apparently it's too late so you know i
was wondering if you had any advice and
how to keep on going man
love you
and the advice will start to come from a
higher power and from the program so
that will help you
you'll get it it's it's interesting
it'll start to get built into you
you just keep going to meetings and keep
listening to people and i would go to
speaker meetings you can go to them on
zoom first if you feel more comfortable
um
and because once you start to feel like
you can keep on going then you're going
to feel like you can go further but
first you got to feel like you can go
and then it will all evolve man i
promise you
i promise you you will have other
opportunities with this
with this person with this child you
will have all of that
you know
all those things are possible but now if
you know that something's wrong and you
continue to do you continue to do it
then you are kind of choosing to suffer
you know you said real
realized it you know you realize these
things so now you have knowledge so once
you have that knowledge if you continue
to do it
then you are choosing to suffer
you know uh
and sometimes you may make that choice
but if it's a continued thing maybe it's
you know and i just said i'm not judging
you i've done it
and that's where self-pity starts for me
i continue to stay in these loops and i
don't even recognize it
i just continue to want to have a re
some reason to suffer
um
[Music]
and i just don't want to see the same
thing happen to you man that's that's
happened to me before you know uh so
anyway just don't feel alone brother and
just keep your head up baby
you know
um
[Music]
because you're not alone man i mean
there's probably 500 000 people
listening to this that are thinking of
you
and that want you to want you to try
you know
they want you to try
you know and i want you to try to i know
it's hard man
it's hard bruh it's hard to [ __ ] try
especially when you have there's a
feeling inside of you like the world
never
it never tried for you
this world never [ __ ] tried for me
but that's that's just a feeling man
you know
and god gave you like a beautiful child
or whatever you believe in gave you a
beautiful child man and you got a voice
you have the ability to care about
yourself enough to call
you have gifts
you have gifts man
and um
[Music]
and i believe that you can do it brother
i believe you can have a new experience
and that's what i want for you because
it seems like that's what you want for
you so
anyway man i'm not trying to preach at
you but uh just letting you know that uh
you're not alone baby okay
oh
and i know right where you're gonna end
up bro
the same place we all are
you know where it is bub
you wanna come up daddy
thank you to everybody that came out and
saw me this week
montgomery augusta columbus
[Music]
that's 89 vote with the come up man you
guys be good to yourselves huh you
deserve it take care of yourselves thank
you for uh loving me when i can't even
love myself at times um i'm grateful to
be a part of this i really am and uh
yeah we tried our best on those shows
man i'd say probably six out of eight of
the shows on the past two weeks have
been really just lights out couple was
just almost lights out you know i'm kind
of a perfectionist and
that's okay you know uh
it's definitely this you know this show
has really picked up a lot of steam so
i'm grateful to be out there and get to
see you guys in person baby and um
be good to yourselves baby
gang
[Music]
well
[Music]
well i just got home and now i'm back
[Music]
what i really wanna do is just come
right back make love to you i'm gonna
come up
[Music]
yeah that's 89 volt you guys are
checking out if you get a chance and uh
we will be
back next week
uh we got a great guest coming in and
then um we'll probably hit a solo
episode after that and uh
that's it
you guys take care again